[Music]
well it's super nice to meet you great
to meet you and excitement out to do
this got exciting times ahead for you
this is an incredible year for me yeah
you know a lot of big big dreams and
goals are gonna be accomplished this
year so July 22nd is the big fight is
all right
yeah July 20th July 20 yeah okay we just
got confirmation we'll be in New York at
the Barclays Center oh wow yeah which is
beautiful I've actually already fought
there before uh-huh
it's where the Nets play just a gorgeous
arena probably about 25,000 screaming
fans
yeah a ton of energy and it's gonna be
broadcast on Fox correct yeah yeah like
a million people are gonna see this
fight yeah I mean based on what the
ratings were before my guess is
hopefully four or five million people
will be tuning in Wow the more the
better so I'm excited that's pretty cool
so it's the super middleweight IBF world
title fight wrecked right and you're
fighting
Caleb plant correct yeah Caleb's a kid
from Tennessee he just won the title so
this is his first title defense uh-huh
very good boxer a champion for a reason
but this is my night I'm really excited
yeah so he is what does he's like 18 I
know with 10 Kos
yeah 18 or 19 I know I'm currently 21 I
know right
well someone's always got to go yeah you
can hear that a lot and how are you
feeling about the whole thing I feel
awesome I mean I've had a long career
like I said 21 and OH has had a lot of
ups and downs I'm sure we'll obviously
get into that but you know this for me
is the culmination of a dream I've had
since I was eight years old
fight for a world title it's my
Superbowl it doesn't get any bigger and
better than this so all the you know
I've got scars on my hands of when broke
my hand in a fight in MSG between all
the health battles I've gone through
broken noses July 20th is the
culmination of everything I've worked
for and so for me it's the pinnacle and
I'm beyond pump for it yeah a lot of
pressure to it honestly is you know it's
a crazy concept to think about for a
fighter right and this is my first world
title fight on a stage like this
you train your entire life I started
fighting at 8 years old but you know day
in day out especially since I've been
pro for 36 minutes
it's a 12-round fight three rounds three
minutes each round and 36 minutes is
gonna change my life
yeah and it's crazy to think the years
either way either way yeah in the years
you prepare for a moment it may even I
might get a knockout it might only last
around you never know but it's crazy how
long you prepare mostly not in front of
cameras and by yourself for a moment
that's so short yeah I mean it's similar
to an athlete who's preparing for the
Olympics like a you know I come from
swimming background I know many you know
I wasn't at that level but I have plenty
of friends that are and their entire
life boils down to you know that moment
at Olympic Trials to qualify for the
Olympic team and then that moment you
know climbing the blocks that you know
the finals of the you know biggest
sporting event in the world where
millions of people are watching and the
race can be anywhere from like 21
seconds to a couple minutes at most and
then it's done yeah you know it's you
know do you you know Connor uh Connor
Dwyer right I was just gonna mention
that yeah I know Connor it's interesting
he actually just text me today cuz I
hold the most you know I'm I hop it on
this show I hit him up to yesterday's I
went on your Twitter and it shows like
who your mutual friends are oh and our
only overlap was gone I texted him I was
like hey you must know this guy yeah
yeah yeah Connors great dude we both
were athletes for this this company that
we were both sponsored by and I met him
through that and actually we have a lot
of mutual friends in Chicago yeah and he
has a very similar story you know I was
listening to his his show his interview
obviously and how he started really late
and even though I started boxing at
eight I really didn't get into it
hardcore until I was and almost like 18
so right that kind of resonated with me
when you know he mentioned he started
getting into it and getting his growth
spurt late in life yeah he really did I
mean he bloomed much later in life for
you know in the historic that's very
very unusual I don't know what it's like
in boxing but for him to bloom that late
as you know I was really a compelling
thing but let's take it back man
yeah starts at 8:00 yeah you know I kind
of know the story but it's interesting
now how your you got in a little scrap
and your dad took you down to the gym
yeah well it's interesting I was playing
a million different sports growing up
and my parents were from the inner
cities Chicago grew up really tough
background my dad didn't even graduate
high school and but created a life for
me and my sister that they never had so
I'm so grateful and appreciative of that
but so while you know I I grew up better
than they did I still had that kind of
inner-city toughness to me mm-hmm and my
dad brought me to a boxing gym at eight
years old I remember one hockey
tournament we were going through a line
and shaking hands and saying you know
good game good game and this kid spit in
my face
and I dropped my gloves and I punched
the kid right in the face because that's
what I'd seen all my heroes do you know
on TV and fights and huh I was just I
was a different kind of kid I think I
loved competition and sports and after
that my dad took me to a boxing gym and
actually the first time I stepped in a
boxing gym at eight years old I remember
I sparred a ten-year-old and I got my
ass kicked and I went into the bathroom
and I started crying and I had a bloody
nose and it's ironic that we're kind of
sitting here talking about fighting for
a world title because as I think back to
that moment I think to myself how much I
hated it at that moment I remember I can
see it so clearly I look in the mirror
thinking I'm never getting in a ring
again so it wasn't like oh man this is
gonna be my path
no it wasn't I loved sports but right
away boxing wasn't something I loved and
it wasn't until later in life that I
really got into it and that one on one
in that competition and most importantly
that adrenaline rush I became addicted
to yeah I'll say there's no better
feeling in the world when you get a
knockout and you jump on the ropes in
front of thousands of people it's it's
the best drug you'll ever take well the
stakes are high you know unlike other
sports I mean you know you're putting
yourself in you know significant danger
just even being there so that in and of
itself I can't imagine you know the sort
of heightened you know adrenaline rush
that comes with that yeah and it
honestly it's a battle of the mind to I
think a lot of people don't realize you
know
people think boxing yes it's a brutal
sport but it's not just two guys
slugging it out the best in the world
it's a game of inches it's a mental game
you know the guys like Muhammad Ali
Floyd Mayweather the iconic greats
understood and had that mental aspect
and knew how to slow the fight down and
knew how to play mind games and you see
when you're in that ring it's almost
more mental than it is physical it's
incredible because you need to block out
the twenty five thousand screaming fans
and everything else and just focus on
what you're doing yeah I want to get
into the whole mental aspect of it
because that's really kind of you know
where I see your your your edge here but
before we even do that what is you know
I'm somebody who I'm a sports fan but
I'd be lying if I told you I knew all
that much about the world of boxing you
know my frame of reference with the
exception of watching an occasional
fight on television
it's just movies and television right
yeah so explain to me the difference
between you know truth and fiction in
terms of like what we see up on the big
screen with the training and the rocky
and the you know all of that versus like
the daily reality of what your life is
like oh it's funny people always ask me
is my favorite movie rocky and then like
and what is training like so yeah I'm
not chasing chickens you know I'm not
running out in the desert exactly yeah
I mean they they amplify all that like
crazy so it's funny even the Creed
movies there's a lot the new ones
there's a lot that you're like okay that
just doesn't happen but yeah a lot of
arm butter yeah you know it's a lot of
crazy stuff going on and I think the
rocky trend kind of started that but
yeah I mean training camps are I'm
pretty intense and especially the moment
before the fight is intense you know
when you're in the dressing room and you
know what's about to go down but
generally training camps consist of you
know eight to ten weeks before a fight
and your training usually two days six
days a week I like to take Sundays off
let my body rest and recover and it
looks like everything from sparring
three four days a week to strength and
conditioning we do a lot of swimming I
do yoga it changes throughout the week
but it's intense it's the most you put
your body
mine through it really is so when you
say to idiot well first of all like yeah
Rocky's not doing yoga yeah like cry our
stuff that we do now yeah but when you
say to a day so and you say okay
sparring you know cardio like what it
what's specifically like alright you go
to the gym in the morning sure and like
what does it look like I can walk me
through a day so generally when I first
started my career we started out in the
morning I don't necessarily do this now
I push everything towards the evening
but because the fights at night because
the fights at night right and I wanted
to get my body acclimated and not to
mention which we'll talk about later
when I had some health issues and start
getting sick my mornings are more of an
issue for me I'm in more pain in the
mornings mm-hmm so for a lot of reasons
we push training back but generally you
know you have cardio in the morning
maybe it looks like a run maybe it looks
like Stairmaster maybe it looks like a
swim and depending on where you are in
camp is how long and how difficult that
is and I really leave that up to my
strength coach and then later on the
afternoon you're doing a boxing workout
and so as I mentioned three four days a
week you're sparring and for people that
don't really know sparring essentially
that's just like a fight except you're
wearing headgear and heavier gloves so
you don't do as much damage to your body
but you're bringing in sparring partners
that really fight the same type of style
as your opponent right so you can kind
of mimic that and work on your specific
game plans and some days your sparring
for rounds some days your sparring 12
rounds you know it closer to the fight
you kind of ramp it up and then usually
about a week out you stop sparring so
for that eight to ten weeks every single
day it consists of some type of strength
conditioning and some type of boxing and
then I'll also integrate in yoga so
sometimes it is three workouts a day or
else if I'm feeling beat up after
sparring I'll tell my strength coach hey
today let's just do yoga or get some
muscle work done so it's very fluid in
terms of what my body needs but that's
generally what a training camp looks
like so that you don't peak too early
and that's really important right so
you're looking at what like five to
eight hours a day during that period of
time yeah I never really break it down
in terms of hours I get that question a
lot it's more of how many training
sessions but I would say
eh yeah that that's that's a fair guess
right there uh-huh
yeah and what's the recovery process for
you
look like I've really dove into this
world of biohacking
and just really getting in touch with
different ways to recover you know I I
was telling you earlier I bought a sauna
I bought infrared sauna in my home I
actually have a cold cold tub at my
house too nice
I bought a cold tub that I have outside
I have it set to a certain temperature
and I'll hop in there for anywhere from
three to five minutes I love that
so contrast therapy is big for me
everything between I started doing float
tanks mm-hmm and that's more the mindset
side I have a nutritionist that has me
dialed in on the glutamine and what to
eat and when to eat and so you know in
cryotherapy as well which is also no
contrast therapy so I'm always playing
with a million different toys oh yeah
and what's the difference but what does
the training look like when you're not
in camp yeah cuz you so you don't go
into camp out of shape you don't try not
to some fighters do and that's kind of a
funny thing about fighters is we
fluctuate and wait so much you know
because I normally fight at 175 this
fight will be at 168 I walk around at
190 pounds and so it's important in any
you know martial artist is usually like
this in UFC or boxing where the last you
know good amount of weight is water
weight uh-huh but you got to be careful
that you don't come up and weight too
much because you'll see guys that
literally maybe they just had a big
title fight and they have a few months
off and they'll balloon up 2030 pounds
and that's just not good for your body
and organs so I've been pretty good in
discipline of in between fights I'm not
trying to kill myself I'm doing a lot of
low-impact stuff but I'm trying to keep
my weight generally between you know 15
20 pounds max of my fight weight right
so how much time do you have to drop
that final amount of weight after
camping before weigh-in
well when you go into camp like you said
you want to be in good shape you know
generally the beginning of camp the
first couple weeks are more cardio based
so that you can start to bring the
weight down and get that you know
fluidity and your body feels good a
lower weight but you know I
I'll have 8 to 10 weeks to start to
bring that weight down I already started
weeks out because in this case I've
known for a long time about this fight
and signed the contract a while back but
really that's when you get scientific
about the weight drop you know for
instance generally I'll hop in the ring
or I'll weigh in the day before so 24
hours before his weigh-ins and pro
boxing and for my last Junior World
title we fought at 175 pounds I weighed
in at 174 0.5 maybe right so I was under
the limit
the next night man I had to be I was
probably a hundred eighty seven pounds
right on ten to 12 pounds and that's
Simon it doesn't make any sense
it's such a weird thing I will say this
you know that is the worst part of the
sport I love all aspects of the sport
but the weight cut any fighter will tell
you you know you're you're up there at a
press conference like a day before
weigh-ins you know and everyone's always
like I feel great I feel a hundred
percent but you're cutting weight like
no one wants to be there it's like the
reality of it make yourself weak and
dehydrated yeah in order to make that
weight and then try to rejuvenate
yourself in a short period of time and
that's when it comes really having the
right team around you becomes important
because it's all about water
manipulation there at the end where I
will flood myself of water drink up to
two gallons maybe a week before
weigh-ins and then systematically bring
it down maybe do a gallon to half a
gallon 0.25 where my body already thinks
is over hydrated so when I hop in the
sauna or I hop in a hot bath and I sweat
out there the rest that excess water
weight I'm not too depleted like my body
isn't in shock right and then at that
point you hop off the scale and it's the
best feeling in the world like I get
more nervous for weigh-ins sometimes
than I do for the actual fight it's
strange
does anyone just say [ __ ] it and like
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna fight
where I'm at yeah so some guys do that
for instance I think when Floyd fought
Juan Manuel Marquez and granted he's in
a position to say [ __ ] it more than a
lot of people because there's strict
penalties so for this fight in
particular there'll be a penalty of
probably 50,000 dollars per pound for me
if I go over but they'll still let you
fight they'll still let me fight but if
you don't make that weight and it's a
title fight you're not fighting
for winning the belt hmm so if you don't
get that waiter under you even you win
that fight you can't be the world
champion I got you so but Floyd came in
I think maybe 2 to 4 pounds overweight
at one point and I think it was a mental
game but he kind of just said [ __ ] it I
think he got fine like two hundred
thousand dollars but the verses are so
huge it's like who cares right exactly
yeah especially for a dude like that
it's just another level so he was like
bucket so I won't buy another car yeah
all right all right so you're eight
years old your dad's like I'm taking you
to the gym you're gonna work this stuff
out here yeah this kid's got a lot of
energy
yeah when is it when is a switch flick
and you're like this is what I want to
do so it's interesting I I started
getting more into boxing at about 15
years old
we complained you were playing all your
pawns football and football hockey
baseball basketball I'm I'm a very
unique situation or person where it's
ironic that I'm a professional fighter
and at this level but I actually don't
enjoy conflict
I really don't I'm not a fighter if you
meet me outside most people majority
people say I can't believe you're a
boxer I don't enjoy conflict I'm not an
aggressive person I don't get in fights
outside of the ring not to mention I get
a lot of trouble now it's probably like
a federal offense since I'm a pro but
that's just never been me but when he
came to sports I was extremely
aggressive sports and competition when
the bell rang or the whistle blew I was
a different animal and for instance on
my hockey team in Little League I played
goalie I had the most penalty minutes on
the team and I was a goalie and anybody
that knows hockey he's like what are you
doing tough to do yeah so where does
that come from I don't know I I think
probably from my father um my dad played
minor league ball for the twins and he
was a professional racquetball player
and he's very type-a aggressive Chicago
Italian dude and I think he had this
ideology that he instilled in us that
win win win like always keep pushing
always keep winning and for better or
worse it made me the person I am even
though he set really high expectations
for me that sometimes I didn't meet but
that's where this competitiveness
sure came in so it was about 15 years
old I I went to Notre Dame so Notre Dame
has a boxing team and they've this huge
event called the Bengal bouts they have
about you know a few thousand people
that come to it and the kids in the
school fighting a big tournament and I
think I first went to that tournament
about 15 years old and I saw Rudy so
when I was like 10 years old being a kid
from Chicago I was like I gotta go to
Notre Dame when I saw this event I said
to myself not only am i can go to Notre
Dame I'm gonna be a boxer there I'm
gonna get good enough be a boxer there
and that's really when it kind of took
off and I started getting better and
better and I was sparring pros by the
time I was 16 years old
mmm so you go to high school and then
you hit the gym afterwards or what did
that look like yeah so I had and once
again a little bit of two sides of the
coin here I was working in finance so
two things I loved were finance and
fighting even in high school I first got
an internship at the Chicago Board of
Trade and most down in the pits and I
love that adrenaline rush tournament
screaming orders and so in the summers
during the day I'd be a cardboard trade
and then at night I would go to the
boxing gym so all throughout high school
I was playing other sports and
continuing and go to the boxing gym
I started at this place called Windy
City Gym in Chicago and there were a lot
of great fighters out of there and
throughout high school I started getting
better and better and then my freshman
year I ended up going to University of
Missouri to be quite honest I didn't
have the grades getting Notre Dame and I
really didn't take school seriously I
took sports seriously but I didn't take
school seriously we're all at Missouri
or no no I wanted to I was planning out
walking on for the football team
because I was getting really good at
football and baseball and I knew I
wanted to play sports I just didn't know
what I loved but it was interesting with
boxing training I love the training
aspect of it with football baseball
basketball I hated practice that's kind
of how I knew okay if I'm gonna get
really good at this I need to choose
something that I'm passionate about and
I can't stop thinking about and I
[ __ ] love and I truly believe in that
for anything you want to do if you don't
in your core love this [ __ ] especially
the pain that we go through don't even
mess around with it right so I realized
maybe around seven
eighteen that I love boxing I ended up
transferring after my freshman year into
Notre Dame because this was just my goal
and vision and I busted my ass to get
the best grades of my life in Mizzou and
transferred in and I joined the boxing
team and the love of the sport just took
off his boxing and nc2 a sport no it's
not yes how did that yeah at work so it
was a club sport where you had some kids
who had fought before so we had some
talented kids but then a lot of kids
that were athletes it originally started
by nu nu Rockne the famous Notre Dame
coach and so there are a lot of nerdy
and football players that were in it and
so that's kind of how the tournament
started and so you get a lot of good
athletes that are in it but so I did
well there and I won all three years I
was there but it was really when I
started fighting I fought in Lycia kha
Golden Gloves I'm not one my class and
that right around my senior year college
and then I started fighting and training
in different pro camps and that's when
top ranked came along top ranks arguably
one of the best promotional companies in
the world so right Bob Arum and top
ranked Manny Pacquiao Floyd Mayweather
Oscar De La Hoya they're all signed by
him so when I started doing well in
Pearl camps and getting the attention of
top ranked and winning a lot of amateur
fights getting a call from them was like
getting a call from the New York Yankees
man yeah you know we just breeze through
like a whole thing that I want to get
into uh
so full first of all it's super unusual
for there even to be a boxing club in
college yeah I don't think there are
many colleges that even have that but
Notre Dame for whatever reason because
of Knute Rockne or whatever has this
tradition that that has to do with is
the Bengal bouts and yeah the service
elements of that that we can talk about
you go into Bangladesh and all of that
but it is interesting that there's this
culture around boxing at Notre Dame yeah
well it's the Fighting Irish yeah and so
that's you know our team my year I was
ended up being captain the team my
senior year we had about 200 guys and
now they actually have women's division
as well so you got some badass chicks
that are in there fighting it out so the
club has really grown since it started I
think in 1934 or something yeah but as
you mentioned yeah it has this service
element to it which is incredible like
my year alone
from ticket sales and everything we
raised over $100,000 and it goes to the
Holy Cross missions in Bangladesh it was
really Notre Dame first going to Notre
Dame that instilled this idea of giving
back and so I ended up going to
Bangladesh for about two weeks and
helping build some schools out there and
huh which we're helping teach English
and provide the basic necessities for
these kids and that was my first time
going out there my senior year at
college to Bangladesh where it was
really an eye-opener and I realized how
grateful I am and how much living here
in America we have and how little the
rest of the world has and it really
taught me a lot of gratitude yeah and
you're able to kind of harness that and
and still like hold that experience
tight and it informs kind of your
perspective today I still think about it
I remember walking through the slums of
Bangladesh and seeing kids and they had
these big smiles in their face and it's
such a cool thing to see when we'd walk
up and help and we'd give them boxing
gloves or food and water and these big
smiles on their face and I was like
these kids are living on dirt floors
when I go back I'm not gonna complain
like life is beautiful life is good and
lucky to be born in this country and it
really changed my perspective on things
you know as a young man mm-hmm so you
start to have some success he win
Chicago Golden Gloves but meanwhile you
kind of have this you know these finance
aspirations right so there was a there's
a kind of a fork in the path you could
have gone to Wall Street mm-hmm and you
had to make this decision whether to
pursue that that kind of career or to go
full in on sport so my senior year in
college I was studying finance and I
actually went through a few interviews I
had internships at an investment bank at
the Chicago Board of Trade and like I
said was finance and fighting but my
love was boxing men and I just knew that
I had a shot to do something and I knew
that finance could wait and I actually
right around when we were getting offers
to turn pro towards the end of my senior
year I had a lot of people that told me
not to do it
and obviously listen I know people have
died in the ring people get hurt just
like any other contact sport I knew the
risks involved and they were like you
have a finance degree from Notre Dame
why are you
doing this and I kid you not you can't
even write this about a month before I
got that call from top-ranked something
changed my life I was reading this study
and I was going back and forth trying to
decide you know do these mentors or tell
me to not do it are they right I listen
to my heart and go for it what the study
did is they interviewed people from all
over the world and I was reading this in
my dorm room different races different
religions different ethnicities the only
thing these people had in common is they
were all on their deathbed they're all
dying they wanted to see what was going
through the minds of people that were
dying right what they found is they
regretted the things they didn't do more
than the things they did I think some
people may have heard this study or
heard heard about it but I never knew
this right and I'll never forget sitting
there once again I can see this moment
clearly sitting in my room in college
and reading that study and on the
computer and saying right then and there
that's not gonna be me [ __ ] it I'm going
for this I'm gonna chase my dream
because whether my first fight I get
knocked out or I break my nose I never
fight again or I fight for a world title
one day which we're about to do at least
I can go to bed at night knowing that
[ __ ] it I went for it
yeah man you don't want to be that guy
who spends his day on the trading floor
and then goes to the bar with his
buddies and talks about like how you
could have been a contender yeah look at
that people think that could have been
me manager like yeah okay Mike exactly
so you get you get success like pretty
swiftly like things kind of kick into
high gear yeah I mean things went fast
early I I started out winning some
fights and they were building me up the
right way you start out with four
rounders six rounders and then I got
some notoriety that most fighters don't
get early in their career I hadn't
sponsorship from Subway and I end up
doing 16 national commercials and two
Super Bowl commercials and that happened
dude so I have a good friend you [ __ ]
that you were on the comp but it wasn't
like no I was an unknown you know I was
for a no at the time I just fought on
ESPN it was my first televised fight and
had a good friend of mine his name's Tom
Busey and he had a lot of connections
and become he's become a mentor of mine
and has been the media world and he knew
the CMO of Subway at the time and so he
I just fought on ESPN and he said listen
you know I actually it's funny I so I
met him in New York right and this is
the first time I met him because he was
a friend of another friend right and the
first lunch that we had and the lunch
was all about you know maybe some
sponsorship opportunities for me he
could be a good connection and I'd had
many lunches and dinners like this cuz
you never know where they lead the first
lunch we had this guy tried to convince
me basically not to box and he was like
why are you doing this and we still
talked about this to this day and he
says that he saw the passion and fire in
my eyes and that's when he kind of knew
okay I'm gonna help this kid out you
know I'm gonna see if I can get him some
sponsors and kind of help him along the
way
and sure enough he said can you stay in
New York another couple days I want you
to meet one of the heads of Subway so I
said absolutely I mean I've been eating
subway since I was you know eight years
old like all my Michael Phelps Ryan
Howard Laila Ali
nastya lute like all these incredible
athletes were on subway commercials so
I'll never forget sitting down with the
subway team and they grilled me like
literally I remember sitting there in
New York and I have a suit on I'm all
nervous and I'm talking to the CMO and
the head of athletes and they're like
well the first thing we want you to know
is that we don't just sponsor athletes
we have famous fans so we actually have
people that enjoy the our restaurants
and actually eat it so they basically
we're saying are you lying about eating
subway constantly you know and I was
like yeah and they were like what's your
favorite sandwich I was like oh I always
get the six-inch Turkey they're like no
no walk me down the line like you're at
Subway and tell me exactly what you get
I kid you not but I nailed it cuz I
actually do go and I was like all right
let's do it so I walk up and I say I
want the six-inch turkey you know I want
no cheese you know and go down the line
and they just seemed disinterested and I
remember them being on their phones and
one guy telling me I'm the one who
signed Michael Phelps like tell us why
you know you at four and oh should be on
this and I felt like I was like begging
for my supper
uh-huh I remember leaving that meeting
and calling my dad and I was so sad I
was like man they just didn't like me
that I don't understand what I did wrong
I thought I told him about my hopes and
dreams and it worked out and he's like
don't worry about it
he goes you know you might have a
hundred of those meetings all you need
is one so I'm sitting in this pizza shop
like literally drowning my sorrows in
food and my dad calls me up two hours
later and he goes man I don't know what
you did but the head of Subway just
called they want to put you on a plane
and get you to Paramount Studios and
film your first commercial and I was
like holy [ __ ] let's so what what did
you miss read I think they were holding
their cards close to their fat close to
their chest kind of thing and a lot of
the people that I met were like wow such
an incredible story I love this and
maybe it's just their New York East
Coast demeanor that they just weren't
impressed but I don't know what it was I
mean maybe they were just I think they
were impressed they just want didn't
want me to know maybe but for whatever
reason next thing I know I'm in LA
shooting subway commercials and less
than a year later I'm sitting around
with friends watching the Super Bowl and
there I pop up and say Mike Lee next to
Michael Phelps to Ryan Howard and I
gotta be honest I felt like I don't
deserve to be up there hmm it was how
did the how did the boxing community
receive it haters yeah which you're
always gonna get and I said a little too
premature right I felt like it was too
premature and they felt like why is he
getting his opportunity and world
champions aren't and if you're me you
know I just went in and killed it for
him on camera
you know I they kept saying how great I
was at the enthusiasm and learning the
lines and all that kind of stuff so who
wouldn't take that opportunity but so
you definitely get some people that were
jealous and haters and as an athlete
dude you get that constantly I'm sure
you get that to people that absolutely
obsessed with the show and people that
say you suck and you got I've learned
throughout the past ten years how to
push that out of my mind but in the
beginning that really used to hurt me
man ice go on Twitter I used to see
articles and people that said I wasn't
good enough I sucked I was this that and
it really bothered me my early 20s yeah
but meanwhile you have all this momentum
you're kind of foisted into the
you know spotlight and the careers going
good right so walk me through kind of
the next phase yeah the next phase of my
life came out of nowhere and it was a
lot of pain so I you know I'm running on
this high and I felt invisible I'm doing
national commercials I'm getting
notoriety I'm making good money finally
I'm fighting I fought in mass square
garden I fought in Cowboy Stadium I feel
like this is it I'm on my way
you know now fighting at Madison Square
Gardens dude
that I just got goosebumps thinking
about that and I do every time well that
is like the movies that's the mecca man
and I'll never forget walking through
that tunnel and thinking once again
you're kind of thinking like do I belong
here you know Muhammad Ali and Michael
Jordan and you know performers and
everybody there's when you walk through
tunnels and you know going the dressing
rooms and stuff there's like pictures
and posters of artists and athletes and
all this kind of stuff and you hear the
roar of the crowd and I fought an
undercard of Miguel Cotto versus Antonio
Margarito an HBO fight so place was
packed and I remember walking through
the tunnel and getting goosebumps and
thinking holy [ __ ] like I can't believe
I'm here and who would have thought you
know wasn't even three years ago I had
no idea it even become a professional
boxer and now I'm walking through the
tunnels with 22 there are 20,000 people
screaming and I'm about to step in the
ring like this is some gladiator [ __ ]
mm-hmm and it was a really cool moment
in fact even that fight I broke my hand
and school cuz I have a big scar on my
right hand I always think about it when
I look at it talk about how incredible
adrenaline is and how incredible
adrenaline type factor is in your body I
broke my hand in the third round that
fight I didn't realize it my hand went
numb a little bit but the pain didn't
even kick in right I ended up getting a
knockout with that hand one round later
we go back to the dressing room and I
have a camera in my face and I'm sitting
next to my dad and all of a sudden I
looked down in my hand and it's twice
the size of my left one and it's almost
like and then the pain kick did it right
away it's almost like when a kid falls
and scrapes their knee and they look up
to the mouth
to my head I'm like a 24 year old adult
and I look at my hand
and I look at his face and his face was
like oh [ __ ] and then boom the pain kick
there but yeah that was a surreal moment
that I'll remember to the day I die
you had another fight where you had to
fight on after breaking your ribs - yeah
right I had one fight I broke my rib in
the second round I had to go eight more
rounds with a broken rib that was some
of the worst pain of my life I was in
the hospital till 4:00 a.m. I just kept
telling myself don't quit I kept telling
myself do whatever you have to do is a
sloppy fight but I was like do whatever
you have to do to win each round you
know so I would I would throw some pot
shots I would hit him and then I would
wrap him up try to breathe a little bit
but round two and a half round three on
that was some of the worst pain and
you're getting hit there boxing has
taught me how to be tough you know I
think after this career I'll be able to
get through a lot because getting
through those moments like that you
realize how tough the human mind is and
how much you can get through and I mean
God you know that with your story it's
it's incredible well when you're in
these heightened moments you have this
level of self-awareness like you know
like this is this is a moment in my life
and I'm gonna remember this for the rest
you know of my days and how this is
gonna turn out depends upon what's
happening in the next nanosecond and the
more you can kind of anchor yourself in
that reality I think it kind of can
override whatever you know you know I've
never I've never fought with a broken
rib but I know what it's like to suffer
like how do you override that impulse to
quit or to you know fall back or to you
know let your guard down yeah I think
that's when you need to tap into the
mind like you said I know for me I knew
boxing is very unforgiving sport so I
was undefeated and once you have a loss
on your record it's very tough to kind
of get back up I'm only as good as your
last fight and I knew that if I gave up
in that moment and gave it up into the
pain down the line I wouldn't get a
chance of a world title I just kept
thinking of that because that's all I've
worked for so I just kept thinking just
push through man just just win every
round
through this because if you quit now
you'll always regret it and once again
back to that 36 minutes and one night I
knew I was just like dude just get
through this another whatever 30 minutes
and you'll be good yeah but that 30
minutes probably felt like eight hours
it felt so long and I remember looking
at my my parents in the stands and
family and I told me I just had this
dead look like I don't want to be here
that they've never seen before and I
think they hated seeing that you know my
sister and my mom have a tough time
sitting ringside and seeing the blood
and yeah you know the agony yeah Wow so
this is back in what like 2012-2013 that
fight was more recent I was Madison
Square Garden was the one that was 2012
I think
uh-huh but I've had various different
injuries along the way yeah let's talk
about the big one I mean you get
blindsided with this you know situation
that you had a really hard time
diagnosing for a long time yeah so as I
mentioned earlier I was on this ride man
I felt invisible I was you know eight
eight no ten and I got to 12 I know and
then all of a sudden we were getting
ready for a big fight I think it was
gonna be my debut on HBO
and I was down in Houston Texas where I
lived and trained and all of a sudden I
just get it start getting really sick I
started getting extreme fatigue
I started getting incredible back pain
joint pain I was getting headaches every
single day depression started to kick in
and at first I thought okay did boxing
cause this you know yeah you getting hit
in the head a lot exactly you getting
the [ __ ] beat out of you of course
you're gonna you know you go to a doctor
with those symptoms is he's gonna tell
you to exaggerate right and I remember
we were about two weeks out from my 13th
fight and we had a media day which bunch
of cameras show up and you're training I
remember I was feeling so shitty I could
barely get through these days and I was
like what's going on I felt like I had
mono
but with worse pain and headaches and I
couldn't understand it I went to the
bathroom I literally almost passed out
cuz I was pushing through so much pain
and then I still mean like localized or
just all over your body it was all over
his and a lot of my joints but the worst
pain was in my lower back and then also
headaches and then along with that just
a lot of anxiety it was just like a
momentum of bad [ __ ] going on right and
so we pulled out of that fight and I was
like something's not right and I'm glad
you know my team cares about me and my
health more than me winning the fight I
spent the next two years in and out of
hospitals trying to figure out what the
hell was going on with me and I only
later found out like a year and a half
in that I got diagnosed when the
autoimmune disease known as ankylosing
spondylitis I had this marker this gene
HLA b27 that we learned through blood
tests and then also just through x-rays
and symptoms it's something that I think
you know maybe I couldn't avoid like
boxing maybe didn't cause it and you
know because you go to all these
different doctors and this is very
common for people to have autoimmune
diseases some people don't get diagnosed
for like 5 years 10 years why is it so
difficult to identify these things this
is where I'm gonna bash modern medicine
and Western medicine but I I think that
ultimately you know we need to look at
the body in a holistic way and it wasn't
until I started going to like functional
medicine doctors that really understood
for instance I walked into some of the
best rheumatologist to some of the best
doctors in the world I did one program
at Northwestern that was called the VIP
program I think I paid 10k out-of-pocket
just to have every top doctor of each
department meet with me analyze me what
their expertise is and then they sit in
a room and they try to figure out what
was wrong with me right
and they saw and they couldn't I get in
his crack in a room and the head guy
says we think you need to see a
psychiatrist and I'll never forget
looking at him and home I basically said
[ __ ] you and I walked out and he called
me later and I apologized I said listen
dude this isn't that like I'll go see a
psychiatrist and I saw one for three
months nothing changed and I said trust
me dude like something's going on you
got but I realized throughout this
process they didn't analyze what I was
eating and they didn't really analyze my
mindset and you know whether I was
meditating whether stress had an issue
with this and really getting down to the
Nitty Gritty until I started seeing
functional medicine doctors it's so
crazy that you would go and see a
battery of
these top shelf doctors and all these
various disciplines and they're not not
asking you any questions about diet and
lifestyle dude and they don't find it
and you find that Western medicine in
general I mean I walk into a room atala
gist and I tell him I started telling
him about my diet and I would come in
with notes and they'd be like you know
what we think you need to try this we
think you need to try this it was all
prescription drugs at one point I was on
eight different drugs right you know the
side effects that come along with that I
was having full-blown anxiety attacks
then I was depressed so they threw me
out lexapro
I was just a shitshow you know it was
the worst time of my life
I I didn't know I was you know having
terrible thoughts even like suicidal
thoughts because I was so depressed and
everything was taken from me and I was
in pain every day and so wasn't until we
really identified what was wrong and I
could start to tap in to diet lifestyle
get the proper medication and start
doing the proper things that I could
really like you know heal myself and
this was like a two-year period this was
a two-year period and it's not over I'm
so much better than I am but it was like
a two to four year period I think you
know this was 2012 to about 2016 where
I'd have a few fights and I kept pushing
and then I would relapse and I'd have
moments where that medication didn't
work and you know I was on Humera for
years and that was giving me rashes and
I wasn't feeling good but I needed it
and I went from eight medications down
to zero mmm dude I couldn't be more
proud of that so walk me through the
process of being properly diagnosed and
then getting on a protocol that's that's
worked for you yeah you know I saw
another it was one of many
rheumatologists I saw and um he
basically told me I said can i still box
he said you can but I wouldn't and
life's gonna be tough for you and I
remember thinking in that stage I got
through a lot of [ __ ] like this this
[ __ ] guy doesn't know like this is in
my mind I'm gonna cure this and I truly
believe for instance I was on Ameri
which I'm no longer on I was on it for
years and I think it got me to a place
where it helped me but I knew that it
wasn't something I'm gonna take for the
rest of my life
I'm not telling people don't stand the
drugs your doctors recommend but I knew
in my heart that I needed to get down to
um even like a spiritual level a mindset
level of where I started meditating like
I would be in hospital beds dude and I
would read Tony Robbins dr. Joe Dispenza
books by Viktor Frankl like I started
consuming myself with this knowledge
because I was like I'm so over this and
I started learning about these
incredible stories of people healing
themselves through their mind and
through diet and through alternative
medicine and I was like I'm gonna do
this that's gonna be mean and so that's
when really I started taking IgG tests
and doing elimination diets and I
started taking like CBD which I'm huge
on and why I co-founded my company soul
CBD started helping me a ton and why I
started meditating like really learning
about visualization meditation as a
daily practice because I truly believe
that disease is caused by being in this
fight-or-flight right which I'm
constantly in as a boxer so I need to
get myself back into that calm
parasympathetic right mindset so that my
body can heal and recover and for eight
ten years I just wasn't doing that and
so yeah that was that was the main thing
yeah it's almost like an Ayurvedic
perspective that your body is comprised
of all of these systems and when they're
not like in a synchronous you know kind
of communication with each other and in
balance then your body's not able to
prepare itself but if you can just get
to that place then the body actually
knows what to do yeah and this is not to
bash Western medicine Western medicine
is amazing for all all manner of acute
things but obviously you know this was
missed for you and you found your
solution in alternative you know
methodologies which is super interesting
I mean this is is an autoimmune disorder
that's kind of localized in the spine
right mm-hmm
so a lot of my pain out to this day it's
gotten so much better but I wake up in
some type of pain every single day
some days are a lot better than others
and I just need to really dial in and
even when I'm in training camp I push my
body hard but for good for years I woke
up an incredible back pain incredible
joint pain but when I started changing
all these things that we just talked
about the headaches went away I don't
know I don't get headaches anymore I had
headaches every
single day and I had this type of pain
and fatigue I mean the fatigue was
brutal dude and how much of that was
being depressed versus the disease I'm
not sure but I actually I started
learning a lot from other people
I kept it secret and I was almost
embarrassed about it for years and then
I decided to write about it one night I
couldn't sleep and I wrote and wrote and
wrote and I ended up submitting my paper
I called it invisible pain to the
players Tribune mm-hmm it's a platform
that Derek Jeter started were you know
athletes write about their experiences
and I was super open and vulnerable man
I talked about what I've gone through
and you know other people that had gone
through this that inspired me to get
better and I was super nervous to put
that out because normally I was not very
open about it but man I received
hundreds if not up into the thousands of
messages on Facebook email Twitter being
like I have an autoimmune disease or I
had this happen your story inspired me
like I have people that I still connect
with on a daily basis that I haven't
even met that are like I just ran an
Ironman or I just did a Spartan Race I
had this autoimmune disease you inspired
me to get back in the gym and do that
was one of the coolest moments most
fulfilling moments of my life yeah I
read the piece it's great it's
interesting though that you had
trepidation about sharing that is that
like a fighter thing of not showing
vulnerability yes or something around
like oh it's this weird disease no one's
ever heard of he must have made it up I
think I grew up with I'm not gonna blame
my dad for this but I grew up with a
father who was very masculine and very
like you just push your problems under
the rug I our house wasn't really an
open honest communication I think at
times I had a great relationship with
him and I still do so I don't mean to
bash that I'm just saying I thought the
idea of being a man and a fighter was
just to bottle it up and not say
anything and after a while I felt like
[ __ ] I need to like talk to people and
be vulnerable because you think about it
like you go in press conferences as a
fighter and everybody says the same
[ __ ] thing I feel 100% man training
camp was great let me tell you some
[ __ ] and you know what honestly I'll
probably get up there this press
conference
say the same thing because it's just
what you say and now I'm gonna be
watching I'm gonna be like you know I'll
probably like oh I feel great which is
true which could be true right but you
never getting my point is you never
getting up there and saying well yeah
three weeks in we thought I broke my
hand and and you know I had this than
that like and dude every training camp
there's always something because if
you're not having some type of setback
in training camp you're not training
hard enough mm-hmm
so it's like this Evan flow so that's
really it was the first time I was like
open and vulnerable and now I talk about
it and I even do a little bit of
speaking - I've spoken to vision 1
athletes 2 different corporations about
the mindset of getting through pain and
pushing through and dude it's the most
fulfilling thing ever I could I could
see myself doing that and trying to help
people get out of pain after my career
and the great irony of course being that
that that willingness to be vulnerable
in that manner ultimately makes you
stronger you have you've can you you've
basically built this you know coalition
of support behind you and all these
people that want to see you do well and
I think there's an appreciation for that
honesty that in the long term emboldened
you and makes you you know a better more
well-rounded person but also an athlete
yeah I was just afraid because at the
time my contract ran out with top-ranked
and I was afraid no one would sign me I
was afraid they'd damage good damaged
goods yeah and it was so liberating just
to say [ __ ] it wasn't that kind of
subway commercial yeah yeah I sold the
sandwiches with my shirt off rightfully
yours well and for two years you're down
for the count and this is this is the
prime of your life right like we need 27
28 something like that yeah I have my
life prime my career uh-huh and and no
no guarantee that you're gonna be able
to call your way back I'm sure a lot of
people thought that's guys it's done a
lot of people did and even I mean I
remember my first fight back I fought on
NBC Sports and I fought another
undefeated fighter and I remember the
promoter at the time I heard was like
we're not sure about this
don't blame me with the matchmaking
don't blame me if Mike loses to this kid
and I won I got a sixth round knockout
but I had so many people that doubted me
to this day dude like because I didn't
have a huge amateur background that kind
of started late so many people that
didn't believe that I would get the 10 a
no 20 you know let alone dude fight for
a world title and that's that like chip
on my shoulder like I want to prove all
those people wrong and I even want to
prove myself wrong in those days when I
doubted myself laying in hospital beds
like that's what July 20 about for me
dude like I know I'm gonna win this
fight but win or lose I've accomplished
so much because I had those days
literally laying in the hospital where I
was like I thought I was never gonna do
anything with my life let alone like
thought about whether I should continue
my life so it's about like proving those
people but most importantly like proving
myself wrong yeah yeah yeah being able
to channel that negativity into fuel
yeah I think so which I mean throw me
wrong like when people say you know they
talk [ __ ] or haters out there it still
affects you like everybody's a human but
nothing like in the way it did before
now it just rolls off so let's talk
about the mindset game you kind of
mentioned at the outset you know there's
so much more to boxing then than meets
the eye it really is the sweet science
and and it's it's the attitude the frame
of mind the you know the ability to be
present and everything that gets packed
into you know what's between the ears
when you step onto the ring that's gonna
make the difference and you've got a lot
of really interesting practices around
this that I want to yeah about well I
started seeing a sports psychologist
kind of early in my career I think maybe
I was training with I was training with
other professional athletes at this gym
called Plex in Houston and I think
someone referred me to this guy and I
remember at the time thinking why am I
seeing a psychiatrist you know I'm not
going crazy is this pre the Tony Robbins
Viktor Frankl okay this is pre this is
when I was like I just want to run crash
yeah yeah like smash people you know it
was very like rocky asked but that's
started opening my eyes up to like
visualization especially I didn't get
into meditation and a lot of the other
things I do until after I got sick and
later on but I started early in my
career visualizing fights
right because there's all this study and
evidence out there that the brain really
doesn't know the difference between
perception and reality you know for
instance I talk about this all the time
you can give yourself a heart attack
just from stress and your thoughts right
that's [ __ ] crazy that's a physical
manifestation that could kill you all
because of your mind right so I was
thinking who's to say the opposite can't
happen so I will visualize every single
fight and what I want to happen with
extreme clarity and what I learned is I
do it with all five senses I'll
literally think about what it looks like
that night when I step in what it smells
like what the blood and sweat will taste
like and I walk through these moments
maybe sometimes it's five minutes a day
sometimes just thirty minutes whatever I
can get into but it's crazy that when I
step into the ring my heart rates lower
and I think auras all levels are lower
and I feel calmer and I feel in flow
state because I think my brain is like
oh you've already been here hundreds of
times mm-hmm so I've done that every
single fight of my career and now I'm
trying to learn how to do it for other
things like you know maybe I'm speaking
in front of hundreds of people and that
makes me nervous or whatever it is but I
truly believe in that brain-body
connection yeah I learned visualization
techniques very young I had a coach a
swim coach who walked me through this
one I must have been like 14 and kind of
developed a habit around that at that
time and I started to get almost
obsessive compulsive about it where I
would like if I had a huge meet like I I
know the natatorium you know I know what
Lane I'm gonna be in and I could do a
visualization that would take me an hour
to go through a race it was only two
minutes long because every little detail
like this is what the bottom of my foot
is gonna feel like when I step on that
block and this is what the temperature
like every minutia of it but the
difference I'm taking this in a place
I'm gonna want your input on the
difference being like in swimming you
can control not all the variables but
most of them you're diving into a pool
is to see you in a lane and the black
you know the black line on the bottom of
the pool and there's not going to be a
lot of intervening things to kind of you
know throw you off whatever trajectory
you're on but
to perform a visual visualization for a
fight it's almost the opposite like you
want as soon as the fight starts
there's eight billion permutations of
what can happen so how can you possibly
visualize every aspect of that so that
you can create that you know safe
comfortable place it's a great question
I've actually I've never gotten that
question I create different scenarios I
never think of myself as losing ever but
I will create scenarios where I got
knocked down and I'll get back up or
scenarios where I lost that round and
I'll get back in it majority of it is
positive I don't take it to a dark place
but you're exactly right
I mean [ __ ] can change quickly one shot
can change a fight so I guess for me
what's most important is that before the
fight starts I'm calm that when the
fight starts my heart rate isn't at a
crazy 180 190 or whatever it is I'm as
calm as can be while the fight starts
but you're right I mean there's degrees
of variability that you just can't
account for and do you do a specific
visualization for your opponent so that
you're like oh I know this person always
this is his move and I know how to like
you know this is what I'm gonna do in
response to that so that's all like
super rehearsed mentally yes I'll dive
into what the opponent looks like what
they're doing so I really feel like that
this is the 300th time we've fought
together so I'll think about everything
between do they have facial hair you
know they have tattoos what their style
is when I throw that punch where they
usually do and it kind of helps me
prepare in training too because I'll
think like okay anytime a guy is double
jabbing against him
he's usually countering with this so I'm
kind of playing those games in my mind
and I like it it kind of gives me it
calls me down you know because there's
so many unknowns in boxing that I feel
like it gives me a sense of okay like no
matter what I got this does that make
sense yeah yeah yeah for sure and it's I
mean it's a great life skill that like
you said you can use for anything in
life you know not just sport but
business anytime you have to do anything
that is anxiety-provoking to kind of
prepare you for it and acclimate to
success do you still use the
technique I do I mean not as you know I
mean when I was like super into mice now
I'm doing a million different things I
do it for public speaking because that
definitely make you nervous ask me up a
little bit yeah yeah and and when I'm
calm on stage then I do my best work but
when I'm nervous then it's like I can't
like I can't catch my breath and then
I'm like you know you spaced out you
don't know what you want to say and all
that kind of stuff what makes you more
nervous like the crowd sighs or maybe
the venue um a lot of it has to do with
how much sleep I got oh wow so much of
it like if I slept well and I feel good
in my body and like I worked out in the
morning like and I just feel myself
that's very calming it really has to do
with venue saw I mean sometimes like a
big venue with a lot of people is is
easier than a small like 10 or 15 people
because you're you're like locked in
with this and if they're not responding
man you're going down you know I'm just
gonna say that Johnny and even with
10-15 people when you're in an
auditorium there's always gonna be
someone on their cell phone you know and
then you see that person it'll kind of
like throw you off like oh I'm doing a
shitty job then right here won't say but
you're exactly right when it's like 10
or 15 people it's so intimate yeah you
know and it makes the same thing here it
makes me a little more nervous and if
it's a big venue like you're going into
Madison Square Garden like I've you know
I've been I spoke it Carnegie Hall like
you there's an energy to that there's a
you know that that kind of you know
sweeps you up it's almost like an I I
approach public speaking like I approach
athletic events it's a very similar
preparation yeah that's a great point
because when it's a small crowd you need
to bring the energy yeah you're right if
it's a big menu the energy is already
there so you just kind of ride with
right and it's easy to be excited
because it's you know a lot of people
yeah exactly
all right so visualization what else
what else is part of the toolbox I
really start getting into meditating a
lot I mean as I mentioned I'm in such
fight-or-flight and if anything that's
more from my health I will find that if
I'm very stressed about something or
overworked you know for instance I like
I said I started this company a few
months back so literally the past few
months is like trying to
work on the company and then also
training and once I very soon you're
getting the training camp like I
completely put that to the side but
there's so many things running through
my head that meditation whether it's
even like five minutes to thirty minutes
whatever it is that day I feel like
really kind of like calms me down do you
have a specific type of meditation so I
used the calm app you know I'm kind of
like I said I'm no master by any means
like I can't go into a room with
complete silence for an hour two hours
like that [ __ ] is that's like next-level
stuff which hopefully I'll get to so I
do like guided meditation calm or
unplugged or whatever it is and that's
can you know that's pretty consistent
for me and I enjoy kind of being talked
through that another thing I love doing
is breathing and I think obviously this
goes along with meditation but for
instance there's a breathing technique
that I'll do in the dressing room this
guy dr. Andrew Weil created it it's
called four seven eight breathing and
essentially it's inhale through the nose
for four seconds hold for seven and then
audibly exhale for eight mm-hmm and it's
just a way to like calm your nervous
system down and I'll do about four
cycles of that and I do in the dressing
room and all of a sudden my heart rate
drops so breathing techniques ones like
that really kind of helped me get into
it and I'll even do it you know but
right before after going in training
yeah do you do that when you start to
feel a flare-up
yes yes I will man and and the part of
it is like is it the chicken or the egg
and I think most people thought immunity
deal with this it's like am I having a
flare-up today because I'm stressed or
am i stressed because I'm having a
flare-up so you don't know but I just
have to trust the process and keep doing
it because there's some days when I get
into meditation where I'm like damn I
feel calm I feel loose then there's
other days where I was like this is
[ __ ] like why am i meditating like
I'm not get a lot yeah so the key is
just being consistent with it for me you
know and the cold therapy too right yeah
matter of it yeah so I mentioned I have
the infrared sauna in my home that I got
that really helps all these studies show
it it helps with rheumatoid arthritis
and different autoimmunity and then I
bought a cold plunge and I usually set
it you know anywhere from like 36 to 40
degree
so it's pretty damn cold and I have it
out of my patio and I just lift up the
top and I jump in for you know three to
five minutes kind of a thing and just
freeze my ass off but I love that it's
like it's like cryotherapy times ten you
know well all of these practices are
anti-inflammatory right exists all about
reducing the inflammation so there must
be certain foods that you have to avoid
for that purpose as well yeah so I went
back and forth you know and as I
mentioned I did i GG testing but I
really recommend that people dive into
foods because the food isn't food is
medicine and so for me when I'm gluten
free and dairy free I'm really good you
know I did that whole thing where say no
to nightshades say no to nuts I did
what's known as a AIP elimination diet
where you do it I did it for like 60
days and you've been here basically
eating nothing like it's it's terrible
and miserable I noticed no effects of it
so I ended up being like okay you know
these type of foods aren't an issue for
me like nightshades and all that kind of
stuff so it's so detailed to exactly who
you are there's no blanket term and once
again the issue of Western medicine like
it's incredible Western medicine saves
lives every day but uh it's to blanket
in general and I think diet is so
specific based on your genes and your
lifestyle and all those things so yeah I
say gluten free dairy free that really
helps with flare-ups and I just try to
eat as clean as possible yeah do you
cook all your own meals I a lot but I
have my meals prepared for me so like
for instance this camp I'm working with
a nutritionist his name's Andy Galpin
he's phenomenal yeah I know yeah he used
to run the Red Bull performance lab
right Andy's done yeah he's been on
Rogan a few times talking about a lot of
this stuff he's just a brilliant guy
he's worked with fighters so he's gonna
help me with a whole array of things but
essentially kind of helping me find you
know someone's gonna cook for me and
have the meals planned out that way
there's no guessing in it you know huh
and I just he tells me what to eat and I
eat it that's the best way in training
camp but when I'm out of training camp
yeah I cooked myself right so you're not
in training camp right now but you're it
started it's as far now it started I
mean we're pretty far out but I've been
training it's not
every day crazy but definitely a few
days a week with cardio with boxing I
actually been sparring already I want to
come into this camp is the biggest fight
of my life I want to come to this camp
ready that way if I'm peaking too early
we can pull back and I have to worry
about it so I've already kind of started
implementing the diet so when does camp
officially start probably May first and
you go out of town for that are you
doing that here I have before so we've
gone to Big Bear we've done high
elevation before I got a chance to Train
we're triple G Gennady golovkin trains
and and Shane Mosley's up there a lot
and I've also done training camp in
alpha to an altitude altitude to huge
aspect of it I actually did one training
camp actually the fight before Madison
Square Garden we trained in Mexico City
because with another fighter that a
world title fight there and I remember
the first day I got there Mexico City
walking up the stairs I was out of
breath yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] I
have to fight a human being here I'm out
of breath walking up the stairs but then
once you got acclimated it was
phenomenal this camp on a stay in LA I
don't need to do the high altitude I
think a lot of times for fighters they
they want to go away and it's like a
discipline thing you know it's focus its
focus I never I don't like to go out I'm
not partying I'm very disciplined I know
how important this is
so I'm actually more comfortable at home
not to mention I've got all my toys I've
got my cold plunge infrared sauna I've
got all my doctors here like it makes
more sense for me here and there's a
boxing gym in on the west side that yeah
Serena there's a couple different I
trained at I started training at a
boxing gym it was called wild card West
you know it's called Churchill boxing is
that Pete Burt yes
Pete's place so I met Pete I met Mark
Wahlberg a few years back he's a big
boxing fan and we became friends and got
to spend time with him on movie sets and
hang out in school and then met Pete
obviously they do a lot of projects
together and I was just so cool to see
guys it's such a high level doing some
really cool [ __ ] it seems like Pete's
obsessed Pete's obsessed with boxing and
he's a great guy
so walk our West in particular and we'll
train at other gyms throughout the West
Side but yeah walk well it's now called
Churchill boxing but
it's cool because you'll get actors and
actresses that come in I mean I'll be in
there and Jennifer Gardner
Bradley Cooper you know all these like
really cool people and then you'll get
some of the world class world champion
fighters too but everyone respects each
other it's a really cool kind of
community it's like only in LA only in
LA amen that's right I'd be like come on
dude you got to get out of town that's
like if Bradley Cooper's like bro come
on we're going out like I got you want
to come to the premiere of whatever
tonight and you're in a position to say
no yeah I say no to that
that's good boy man yeah that's a good
point no I
you definitely say no to some tough
invites and some tough things except
Wahlberg he's got discipline that guy
wakes up at like 2:30 in the morning to
work out I got to tell you I I spent a
lot more time with him a few years back
he was one of the most disciplined
hard-working guys I ever met I remember
we'd be I was on the movie set for him
when he filmed one of the transformer
movies and he would be in there we'd be
hanging out he just got done working out
and he'd be taking calls then he'd be
learning going over his lines it was
non-stop for him dude and he'd be up at
4:30 5:00 a.m. working out you know so
maybe two days he and it's credit to his
success I mean that's that's why he is
where he is he's a discipline dude it's
an interesting time where there's a
couple guys who kind of flipped that
equation you know people sort of look at
actors other dilettante or whatever and
you got guys like Wahlberg and Kevin
Hart and the rock who are sharing what
their day in day out looks like in fact
those guys are working you know 20 hours
a day and unrelenting like discipline I
mean I don't know when they sleep I
don't know what marks these I think
ultimately like I said earlier those
dudes must just have passion like crazy
and I know Mark of course they do you
know they're like they couldn't sustain
their lifestyle if they didn't if they
weren't fueled by like some deep like
deep deep National Drive that's gotta be
it yeah those guys are doing some pretty
incredible stuff yeah so all you gotta
do is go live with Wahlberg get ready
yeah yeah he'd love that yeah just move
in yeah but uh well actually he did a
great job on the fighter
that movie was oh I wish they
make a sequel honestly I watch a lot of
boxing movies we were talking about
rocky early yeah
the boxing is so terrible in most movies
because it mark is an athlete and mark
actually did really well I thought you
know Jake Gyllenhaal did well too in
southpaw yeah Kurt yeah Kurt Sutter is a
friend of mine wrote that movie did he
been in here yeah okay I actually I saw
him that Jack wasn't really Oh Jake yeah
Jake yeah yeah he got shredded but now I
was good for I thought it was good yeah
and Antoine Fuqua who's become a friend
of mine as well was the director of that
movie and he's done some stuff with Marc
and whatnot Antoine loves boxing but
Antoine really made the details of that
movie you know so often as a fighter you
watch the movie and you watch him for
instance taping up in the dressing room
or putting a certain glove on you're
just like it doesn't work like that
but he really like went to boxers and
like talked to us and talked to people
in the game and was a student of the
sport and you could see it in the movie
cuz it was like oh the Commission's
always there watching hand wraps yep
those are the hand wraps that you
actually wear those the gloves so
everything was really dialed in and for
me as a fighter I loved seeing that you
know which movie got it terribly wrong
oh come on I mean I looked like eBay
like like I love Stallone I've never met
him or anything but I think he's rocky
changed the game and I love loved those
movies but yeah dude like guys rocky
he's taken haymakers and still standing
it's a ridiculous movie but but yeah
iconic so yeah in terms of like actually
how good how close to the real thing it
was yeah Rocky was way off what in your
opinion makes for a great box or like
what's the difference between a great
boxer I'm liking okay about a good boxer
great question I think staying calm in a
heated moment I think hand-eye
coordination and I think discipline
often boxing does come down to skill but
it does come down to will comes down to
who wants it more who wants it
who wants this more essentially and I
think that combination is dangerous I
mean you've got guys like Floyd who have
incredible skill and can change the game
it's a game of inches and they roll
and they get you off your rhythm and
there's a few fighters like that
but a lot of fights can be won with
Pierre well it's two guys duking it out
and when you get hit really hard you
know I've been hit so hard in the ring
you can't feel your legs I got knocked
down my seventh fight I remember getting
up at the count of nine and barely
beating it and thinking what are you
gonna do now you've got 45 maybe a
minute left for the round just survive
you find that some guys are great in the
gym and they're incredible in the gym
when it comes to fight night the lights
are on there's 20,000 people it's a
different story
so who can mentally become in those
moments I think it's the difference
between good and great fighters do you
think that will can be taught or is that
just something you know it's a great
question I'm not sure I think maybe it's
taught in a way when you're growing up
there's certain things that are that are
just learned I'm not sure maybe it
depends on your your life and all that
but if you don't have that will and that
that gut instinct to win no matter what
at a young age you're not gonna get it
yeah I just I don't think you're gonna
get it how do you maintain your
equanimity when you get punched in the
face man I mean in a weird way you
almost have to like like it it's it's
kind of weird like even I'll tell you
what like you're always you're a little
nervous or anticipatory for a fight but
once you get hit a few times you feel
better it's weird because you're like
okay I feel it I know what he's got you
know and so you almost like look forward
to that exchange so you're kind of like
so you give me this so you've got you
know what you're dealing with you mean
yes you kind of know what you're dealing
with you know it's before the bell rings
where you're like feeling each other out
that's more nerve-wracking once you're
in the fight you're kind of like okay
I've gotten hit by some shots or I've
blocked some shots I feel the rhythm you
feel more comfortable you forget about
everything else
but yeah I mean dude there's moments
when yeah I got hit so hard I broke my
nose and it's just pure well man it's
like telling yourself stay calm and keep
pushing forward
but yeah it's you got to be a little bit
sick in the head to get into the sport
obviously I would imagine you have
certain things you're really good at
strengths in the ring and then
weaknesses when you're preparing for a
fight how do you figure out like which
to focus on is that contingent upon your
opponent like you fo get like I'm really
strong here let's develop that or I
really need to work on these weaknesses
yeah so there's a famous saying in
boxing styles make fights essentially
what that means is whatever style your
opponent has or those two fighters will
have will dictate how the fight goes so
maybe some guys are more Floyd
Mayweather ask where they sit back and
they counter a lot maybe there's some
guys that are more Mike Tyson ask that
come forward and are bulldozers how
those styles are dictates how the fight
is so it's important knowing what kind
of style your opponent has and what your
strengths are and kind of being honest
with yourself and saying okay I need to
either come forward and break this guy
down and break his will or I'm gonna box
him all night because that's my strength
so it really comes down in training camp
working on a few specific whether it's
punches or combinations or more of like
a mindset of what you want to do against
that opponent based on their strengths
and weaknesses so styles make fights is
the best way to say yeah and so with
respect to Kaleb specifically keep that
under wraps or yeah we definitely do XY
hey when does this area no I mean listen
like I said before he's uh he's a very
good boxer and he's slick I mean there's
there's no one I'm not giving away
anything by saying that he's more of a
boxer he likes to move around I'm more
I'm you know a bigger guy I'm coming
down I'm 175 I'm a true light
heavyweight I'm a power puncher I've got
heavy hands so it will be that game of
you know boxer versus the big puncher
and I can box too I'm athletic I can
move too but yeah I mean no one's
anybody who knows boxing looks at our
two styles and you know and they know
it's what's up what is the state of
Union of boxing right now I mean it used
to kind of dominate yeah you know the
media when there was a big fight like
time stood still but now with the rise
of
UFC and the N MMA I mean that's really
kind of taken over in a big way yeah and
and I'm interested in you know how you
kind of perceive how boxing now fits
into that world
I think boxing is coming back I mean you
see especially fights overseas you see
guys like Anthony Joshua's one of the
heavyweight champions that will
literally put 70,000 people in a seat in
Wembley or wherever they end up fighting
over there in London it's on a surge but
really honestly comes down to the
heavyweights in the prime of boxing and
the heyday of box saying you had
American heavy weights you had Evander
Holyfield you had Mike Tyson people love
to see big heavyweights cuz one punch
can knock knock you out and change
everything and then I also think that
UFC came into play and took some market
share and I think that a lot of big
athletes guys that normally would have
gone into boxing are now going into
football are going into other sports you
know a guy like LeBron James would have
been a great heavyweight fighter but he
decided to go into basketball and I
don't blame him he doesn't get punched
in the face and he makes hundreds of
millions of dollars and you can make
that as a fighter but it's tough to get
to that point so I think you kind of
have all these factors coming into play
and then not to mention the bureaucracy
and [ __ ] of boxing I mean this is a
dirty sport you've got promoters there's
no regulatory body right so if you think
about that you've got the NBA the NFL
you got a commissioner in each one
boxing is regulated state by state so
you've got promoters all over the world
that are kind of just doing what they
want and promoters that hate each other
to the point where they won't even work
together so then you've got a promoter
that's got a great heavyweight and
another heavyweight which situation
right now between Tyson Fury and Deontay
Wilder they should had a rematch right
away and fought but they're essentially
in different promoters different teams
that can't agree on terms so that's hurt
the sport in terms of big matchups as
well well I think we also you know are
due for like another massive star you
know like somebody like a Mike Tyson
that just captures the imagination of
everybody yeah you know and I think that
would you know be like a sea change and
how we all perceive the sport I agree
there's some stars out there you'd be
surprised I mean the highest-paid
athlete in the world is a boxer Floyd
Mayweather and I know he's retired but
then you've got Anthony Joshua you've
got Mexican kid named Canelo Alvarez
who's a huge star you've got
Deontay Wilder Tyson Fury these are
maybe household names kind of if you
like sports so I think it's it's doing
well uh-huh yeah well we'll see what
happens on July 20 20th man I can't wait
do you get do you get drug tested yeah
yeah everything by wada
the world anti-doping agency which you
have to account for your whereabouts you
know all that kind of stuff yeah you get
tested you throughout camp or before
after the fight you know and that
depends on each state but yeah they they
make sure that everybody's playing on
even-even field which is you know
awesome - what sport nice can you do you
take supplements any kind of supplements
you have yeah yeah you got to be careful
so I'll take you no vitamins or anything
that my nutritionist recommends or
anything that I've been reading about
and learning about but first things
first I'll clear with my lawyer you know
cuz the worst thing in the world is get
popped for something it happens
sometimes guys get popped
sometimes they're lying sometimes
they're not but you get popped for like
tainted stuff and you thought you were
taken so yeah at this level you just got
to be careful right and so meanwhile
while you're pursuing this you're also
running this business yeah a t-shirt of
it yeah the CVD company so walk me
through
I know CBDs played a big part in your
healing from yeah from a s and now has
led to this kind of entrepreneurial
venture yeah so you know as I mentioned
I I've always had an entrepreneurial
mindset but wadda and early 2017
approved CBD took out the banlist and so
I started taking CBD throughout this
journey and I noticed how much it helped
me you know and there's reports out
there of it helping inflammation sleep
anxiety honestly all the things I was
having trouble with some people are
obsessed and loved it
some people maybe don't but there's no
toxicity with it so I knew that at the
time I could take it while I was taking
other medications and then I started
weaning off medications and I've been
taking it for years now and I'm
absolutely obsessed so my vision and why
my sister and I her name is Angie why we
started the company Sol CBD was to help
people with anxiety sleep and pain and
that's where it came from and so we
started less than nine months ago and we
were like I gotta share this with people
you know and so literally after my last
fight I've been diving in as an
entrepreneur we now have about maybe
four or five employees and it's just
absolutely taken off like resounding
testimonials from people who it helps
and if anything I'm just I want to
spread the message that like plants can
heal you know what I mean and one
important thing of a lot of our line is
we have zero THC so I've sent this off
to a lot of my buddies that play in the
NFL and other professional athletes and
they care about that so that way they
know that everything you're taking is
zero THC and your final and drug tests
right yeah and you take it topically or
you it's like a drop right yeah so the
most efficacious way sublingually is a
teacher underneath the tongue and you
hold it there that enters the blood
brain barrier faster and essentially
with CBD does is it activates the
endocannabinoid system which all humans
and mammals already have in their body
so underneath the tongue gets in faster
but we have capsule form we have a pain
cream so I'm taking it every single day
and what is the experience of taking it
then for you like what it what is the
impact of it the first thing for me is
it calmed anxiety as I mentioned on all
these medications I think just my
chemical levels were messed up and I
started taking the CBD and I started
noticing just general calmness in
general well-being and listen you can
point to placebo or whatever you want
all I know is it works for me and so I
started taking it more and more and then
as I started taking stronger doses it
started helping me with pain and
inflammation so I'll literally take it
every single night and I'll take it in
the morning as well sometimes throughout
the day and it started helping me more
with inflammation and sleep as well but
I started taking it for anxiety because
I was having like full-blown anxiety
attacks man
it was crippling stuff mmm yeah I've
only taken it a few times I've never
taken it to address any kind of you know
acute symptom or just like hey you know
everyone's like I took it and I was I
didn't notice anything it's not like a
drug where you're like suddenly you feel
different yeah but I did notice I guess
there was a I'm sure it was a anxiety
reducing you know kind of experience but
I got like really tired interesting you
know I slept really well that night but
I just felt kind of a little bit just
like like it drained me a little bit
yeah and listen I I'm not saying it's
the end-all be-all and I'm not gonna sit
here and be like but I've never he's the
reason we're back in the ring if I had
yeah yeah but no I'm not and I'm not
saying yeah I'm just saying like
probably everybody's different and if I
had like an acute anxiety situation or I
had some kind of pain that I was trying
to address
I would certainly you know try it for
that yeah I just think we're finding in
general hemp and cannabis are playing
huge roles and we're seeing kind of like
the conversation changes like now hemp
is completely legal and certain states
are legal and I honestly think it's a
plant that maybe doesn't work for some
people but it's helping a ton of people
you know and how is it running a
business when you're trying to train
here damn busy man I mean now now when I
get in training camp you know I have a
proper cooi hired and we have a
president that we're bringing on and we
brought in proper investment and so we
have a whole team and they know starting
basically now I'm putting my head down
I'm just training but yeah there were
months there after the fight that I was
literally I was in between fights we
were negotiating different contracts and
fights but I'd be up running business
man like - taking out fires every single
day hiring you know making changes
there's always something going on so but
it's been fun it lights me up and I know
that you know being an entrepreneur
something I want to do the rest of my
life
is it a direct-to-consumer model or yeah
selling in a retail yeah everything we
sell online my sole CBD com shameless
plug all right but yeah everything we
sell online direct consumer we're
planning on rolling out into reach
later on the year but obviously like CVS
and Walgreens are now running CBD has a
couple of weeks ago so the big the big
guys are getting into it but you can you
sell it in all 50 states
yes as long as it's under 0.3% THC which
we have 0% THC which is huge we'll
probably run a full spectrum line which
means it'll be you know have a little
bit THC in it later on but it fits with
our brand better and me as an athlete
zero TCB yeah we sell to all 50 states
and what are the lessons you know
somebody who came up interested in
finance potentially was headed to Wall
Street and now is you know wearing this
entrepreneurial hat what are the lessons
of business and sport like inform each
other were you it's a great question
well there's so many boxing analogy z'
that i say you know you get knocked down
seven times you get back up eight like
dude I can't tell you how true that is
there were so many days the first were
in our ninth month but and i i've
started another business before early in
my career with couple partners that
failed and it's crazy through that
failure in that business i feel like i
got my MBA so my biggest lesson is like
if you want to go into this and be an
entrepreneur or whatever it is in life
know you're gonna get knocked down dude
and you just got a no I got to get back
up and tomorrow's a new day and so
there's always something that you're
freaking out about and it's about
managing the highs and lows that's what
boxing and the sickness has really
taught me I've had some really high
highs and I've had some really high low
man lows but um it's about managing
those highs and lows and knowing that
like I said you get knocked down seven
times you get back up eight and you know
all you can really do is a famous saying
my strength coach name's Gabe Rangel he
tells me all the time he says he's an ex
Special Forces Marine so he's one of my
best friends and he's seen some terrible
things you know overseas he's done
multiple tours and he always tells me in
camp control the controllables and
control the controllables basically
means just worry and focus on what you
can control right when you start
worrying about what if this happens what
if that happens whether it's boxing
business life that's when you start to
go in a wrong direction so I always tell
myself control the controllables and
that kind of saying that Gabe taught me
and that
him and some of the Marines have gone by
really helped yeah the more you rely on
that or the more you kind of invest
yourself in that the more you realize
there actually aren't that many things
that you can control you know what I
mean and most of our energy is spent
obsessing on the eight billion things
that we can't control
thinking that we can control them but a
healthy appreciation for how little
control we do have over basically most
of the stuff in our life
allows you to more deeply focus on those
few things that you can control and
release the rest yeah yeah I mean you
said it beautifully yeah I mean your
training so all you can all you can
control is what you eat you know how
much you sleep and what you do when you
get into the ring and your training you
know and yeah everything else is a
variable that's out of your hands and
that speaks a lot to the meditation and
mindfulness that really the more you can
be in this present moment and it's very
difficult but the more you can just
focus on this present moment and control
you can control the better off you're
gonna be probably more successful you're
gonna be people all the time like oh
you're running an ultra marathon or
you're in this long race and like when
you're starting to suffer and you're in
pain like how do you not quit and it's
like oh well you'd be present all that
but no-one's punching me in the face
yeah throw that in there and then like
try to crap like I I don't know how you
could possibly do that oh yeah baby
you're going a lot longer than I thought
I remember time is elastic man you know
what I mean like your relationship with
time changes like I said you're getting
punched in the face that thirty Seconds
feels like three hours you know it's a
good point I just think it's you know
maybe we're wired differently because I
sit here and thinking you know hearing
about your ultra marathons and stuff and
I think to myself I don't think I could
do that you know it's just a different
thing yeah but uh it's different kind of
pain for sure yeah less acute but how do
you howdy
so how do you deal with or think about
fear I think fear is an incredible tool
you know because fear in a sense is the
reason why I'm gonna train my ass off
for this fight and fear is why I work so
hard to build my business a healthy fear
I think is important you know I like
this scent courage
about not being scared not having fear
it's about courage is about pushing
through it right so I think if you can
use fear as a tool and almost like a
counter punch sorry for more of the puns
but you roll off the punches and you
counter punch I think it's a beautiful
thing so having that fear if I didn't
have fear
I wouldn't train I wouldn't train hard
I'd be like whatever
but when stakes are high that fear are
kind of used as an asset you know what
about when you're in the ring when
you're in the ring I'm more skier I'm
more scared of losing than getting hurt
I'm more scared of messing up than
getting hurt which as I say out loud is
probably crazy and stupid because the
first thing you should think about your
safety but I'm more concerned with with
winning and so for me that fear just
it's a different type of fear I know
from the outside looking in it looks
like a brutal sport intense and it is
but it's more of a fear of not
performing well and when you're in the
ring like I said you just have to stay
calm and just trust the process and
listen some fights don't go your way and
it is what it is but at the end of the
day like I said before about the reason
I wanted to turn pro there's a weird
thing in boxing where and I've hopped in
the ring at fights where maybe I didn't
train as hard as I should have and that
little sense of doubt like [ __ ] could I
have run another mile
could I have sparred another round
that'll kill you so if you go all out
and you give it everything you have in
training camp you can step into the ring
with this feeling because I've had both
feelings both ways but you can step into
that ring and feel like well dude no
matter what like I did everything I
couldn't prepare for this so let's just
let the chips fall where they may
yeah have you ever been in hit so hard
or in a situation where you're like I
can't do this anymore man yeah for sure
I mean the broken rib the when I broke
my nose when I got knocked down my six
or seven fight you have those moments of
like doubt and you can't do this but
yeah I'd be lying if I said I didn't but
ultimately the will to win and push
forward kind of you know overcomes that
but
yeah I mean I'm human man you you get
those moments and this is an elite-level
we're fighting at and talented guys and
so yeah I think anybody who doesn't say
they've had moments like that they're
probably lying yeah
well walk me through the kind of ritual
like the pre-match ritual and the reason
I want to explore this a little bit is I
think for anybody who's listening we all
have things that were working towards
whether it's a big presentation to your
boss or you know you're gonna run your
first marathon or you're gonna give your
first speech or whatever it is like
there's always you know something
looming in the distance that we're kind
of trying to gear up to be our best self
for and I think there's something to be
said for really canonizing like a
specific approach to those events so
that you can show up and be your best
self and that's gonna look different for
different people but you know what is
your ritual for getting your head right
like when you're right on the precipice
of like walking out there mmm well like
I said I do the breathing technique back
there and the weeks before I'd been
visualizing you know every morning when
we're in the hotel and about to leave
for the arena I say a little prayer and
I kind of do a little visualization and
I kind of I thank God and and basically
wish for both of us to I honestly do I
wish for both of us to come out healthy
you know I when I go in there I don't
wish a will on my opponent I never have
and I've even had opponents that have
and a face offs literally you know call
me the most ridiculous [ __ ] you'd
imagine and after you this and after you
that and when I step in the ring in the
bell rings I'm not thinking about
hurting them out of anger I'm only
thinking winning and I'll do anything to
win right but I figure it's not a great
fuel source good not for me and maybe
like guys like I said Tyson it was but
for me when I come out of the ring you
usually see me I'm smiling like dude I'm
smiling I feel loose when I'm loose and
I feel like I'm having fun I perform
better when I perform like I'm gonna
kill this dude I don't when I'm thinking
that I don't perform well so I always
kind of say prayer every single one and
I
I say you know let me perform the best I
can thank you for this opportunity let's
keep us both healthy but you know let me
let me do my thing
and it's really just little things like
superstitions for instance I always put
my left sock on my left wrap on my left
glove on every single time everything is
left first left shoe so these little
superstitions give me comfort
but yeah it's staying calm and breathing
and kind of moving through it and then
just kind of doing the damn thing so
it's it's one of those things I think if
you can find your routine you're gonna
be well off it's when there's too many
other variables that you can't control
that you that you really kind of get
thrown off course mm-hmm so for me it's
like trying to wear the same thing and
say the same things in my head and eat
the same thing and then you know before
I get in a dressing room and wrapped up
and all that kind of gives me a little
bit of confidence yeah but none of that
is a value if you haven't been doing it
all along like put all the work in right
so you show up on that day and it just
unfolds in the way that you visualized
it because you visualized it a million
times and it feels comfortable and
normal yeah I remember my first fight I
fought actually on national TV I fought
on Fox Sports I thought oh my hometown
Chicago and I remember you get to the
arena and we were walking in and I
remember walking towards the ring just
to take a look at it for anybody came in
and I was so nervous I couldn't feel my
legs and I thought to myself [ __ ] this
better go away it was my first pro fight
and it's such a different world because
in the amateurs you wear headgear you
have bigger gloves you feel naked you're
pro fight because you walk out there
you're shirtless no headgear you've got
these 10 ounce gloves you can feel your
knuckles through cameras in your face
sure enough once I got to the dressing
room and stayed calm and I walked
through as soon as I started to walk to
the ring on the actual you know moment
of the fight I felt calm I felt my legs
again but for a good like hour I could
barely feel my legs when nervous ever
since that fight now I'm good like I
never get that feeling again
so when you
on the way in and you guys are like nose
to nose and there's all the [ __ ] talk
and all that kind of thing like how much
of that in general and not necessarily
just with you but with other you know
your fellow boxers like how much of that
is just performative [ __ ] and then
behind the scenes when the cameras are
off like you're cool with EJ yeah or
like after the fight your bros or is it
really like what's being portrayed you
never rose after the fight you always
have mutual respect like I respect every
single opponent gets in the ring with me
for sure I'm not really [ __ ] talker
I've never have been in press
conferences and you'll see this leading
up multiple press conferences interviews
we do I mean obviously if it gets heated
you're gonna say some stuff when you're
face to face but I usually don't say
much it's not really my style but yeah
you see some fighters that kind of
really amplify it to kind of whatever
sell more pay-per-view and like Floyd
and Conor McGregor when I fought I think
a lot of that was pageantry but a lot of
it is like perfect showmanship oh and
listen they sold the hell out of that
show and they made so much money so you
know all for that but that's just not my
style so I really don't go into it that
way I don't like talk a lot of [ __ ]
induce things just to get attention but
I would say the majority of it's pretty
real man like you're about to go to
battle with this dude and you've always
got like his entourage and your
entourage chirping and barking while
you're you know and that adds to the
fuel so you need to bring Wahlberg with
you yeah yeah bring mark you know yeah
and Pete but yeah so you always got
those guys that are chirping in the
background which kind of adds to it so
yeah cool well uh I wish you much luck
my friend Thank You July 20th I'll be
tuning in and uh really great to talk to
you I had a great time oh man it's been
an honor I feel good I feel great cool
so if people want to dig on Mike please
just set the DVR or make an appointment
watch the fight July 20th and my sole
CBD is the website if you want to check
out that and work out where else people
go to learn more about you I guess you
know Instagram official Mike Lee
and then Facebook Mike Lee and yeah
usually I'm more active on Instagram
that's what I'll show a bunch of stuff
about training and leading up to the
fight and all the fun stuff
cool man thank you brother thank you
come back and talk to me about it after
the fight let's do it I'll bring the
belt all right yeah all right man that's
a promise that I got you
cool peace
[Music]